[Music]
all right just hours ago former Intel
committee chairman congressman Devin
Nunez filed a 250 million dollar lawsuit
against Twitter in Virginia state court
alleging the social media company
negligently failed to remove defamatory
and malicious tweets about the
congressman and his family Twitter is
declining comment tonight but here to
talk about this lawsuit and much more
California Congressman Devin Nunez you
do have a high bar we all need that
because if you're a public figure you
need actual malice and what's known as a
reckless disregard for the truth or else
I would sue people every hour of every
day
but it's harder it's not like in the
case of the Covington high school kid
tell us about the suit yeah so this is
the first of many Shawn and what we're
doing here is we're actually going after
Twitter first because they are the main
proliferator and they spread this fake
news and the slanderous news so if you
look at the lawsuit I think the night
people can go and look at it on Fox News
it's all there but what were the case
were basically making is is this was an
orchestrated effort
so people were targeting me there were
anonymous accounts that were that were
developed and look there's not supposed
to be these accounts aren't supposed to
exist Twitter says that they don't have
accounts that do this so like I said
this is the first of many lawsuits that
are coming but it that there were
several fake news accounts or whether it
was regard to the Russia investigation
or to me and we have to hold all of
these people accountable because if we
don't our First Amendment rights are at
stake here this isn't 20 years ago Sean
what's happening is is that is that
Twitter becomes the gaslighting for all
of the news and when they're regulating
us they're regulating what people can
see on my tweets which they've done and
then they're there proliferating out
things that they agree with with the
algorithms that they develop they need
to come clean where they are content
developers that's right summer they a
shadow' ban me well and and he denied
that that ever went on and he said he
wants to be fair but you didn't you have
not
your analysis has not shown that it is
fair across the board and that a lot of
these social media sites are in fact
using those algorithms if you will or
their behaviors to advance one side
which would then be what a political
donation for Democrats well how is it
that every day there's conservatives
that are being banned so you know look
they don't gonna want to call it shadow
banning that's fine they can call it
whatever they want to call it but the
fact of the matter is is people could
not see my tweets okay so now but if you
move forward if you get emails from
Twitter it's constantly left-wing stuff
it's constantly fake new stuff so I
think if Twitter wants to be in the
public square and they don't want to be
a Content developer they should come
clean give us all your algorithms how is
it possible that I can be attacked
relentlessly hundreds of times a day by
fake accounts that they claim in theirs
in their Terms of Service should not be
there so I guarantee you if I put
something out that was sexually explicit
or attack someone personally they would
they would stop it they would say this
is a sensitive tweet they never did that
to any of the people that that were
coming after me or other conservatives
so and this is more about this is more
than just conservatives every American
should care about this if they care
about the First Amendment because the
press is definitely changed you've said
it numerous times the press is dead and
that's why if we don't go and clean this
up and I've been actually said this on
your show a few weeks ago this is part
of the continuing Russia investigation
we're not going to just let all these
fake news stories that were written
about this investigation about this hoax
that were lies we're going to challenge
every single one of them in court we're
just starting with Twitter well the
thing is is it's so influential and
you're talking about so many if not
millions billions of people you know
Facebook and some others that it's
incalculable how much that assists a
narrative or a point of view let me ask
you this the new and there's a former
house Intel committee chair it's been
frustrating as somebody who has been
trying to get to the bottom of this
whole hillary getting a past FISA abuse
an attempt to to undo a duly elected
president bludgeoning him
false Russian lies etcetera now that we
had or page struck the McCain aide and
this new information about Christopher
Steele and now that we know that
everybody was warned in August long
before they leaked this information
knowingly to the American people and
then used it as the to quote your memo
the Grassley gram memo is the bulk of
information and the FISA applications
how much more is coming because I'm told
this is only the beginning of what will
be an avalanche of information that it
has been hard to get out but it's now
coming yeah slowly coming so this was
all a result of the task force that we
set up last year we have now sent over
about 50 names to the new chairman of
the Intelligence Committee that we would
like to interview to continue this
investigation there is also the
information that is still classified
that we would like to be declassified
and that is primarily 20 pages of the
last FISA the Bruce or 302s the FBI
reports that Bruce or was involved in
its and it's critical to have those
because as you know Bruce or there's a
central figure in this just like Andy
McCabe and the whole Clinton bought and
paid for
Russian lies the dossier we knew before
the election it's all not true and steel
says it himself right and and also why
it's so important John part of the
reason that I'm starting with Twitter in
these lawsuits and going onto the fake
news stories it's important to know who
was behind putting those fake news
stories out Wow alright we're going to
follow this very closely I think there
is a there's a lot to this story a lot
more than meet the eye on its surface
congressman thank you for being with us